thank you hi good afternoon everyone
thank you very much Nick for the
introduction and to the Symons Institute
for inviting me as well as for this
great semester program that I have
really benefited from participating in
so I'll talk about finding low rank
matrices and other structured objects
and we'll start with some very simple
problems
so I actually dick just told me that the
purpose of this talk is to get anybody
who knows about this topic board in the
talk so it's free well we will do that a
lot of it for those of you who have who
know about finding sparse vectors and
low rank matrices it will be another
review maybe and definitely boring so
but there will be some interesting stuff
hopefully in towards the end and we will
talk about some open problems in this
area okay so first we will be looking at
problems that go by the name of linear
inverse problems which means for example
you want to find a signal X that lives
in RN given linear measurements Y that
is a matrix Phi times X and they are M
of these and that this is a linear
system of linear equations but it's
under determined so M is typically much
much less than n and in a way you're the
Y's are compressed measurements of the
unknown object or signal X and we would
like to reconstruct or recover the
object or estimate the object and the
key is the X signal here is often not
arbitrary but has some kind of a hidden
structure and various notions of low
dimensional structure that we will
mention and the question we one wants to
answer is how many measurements are
needed
meaning how big should M be for any
reasonably like polynomial time method
of computation reasonably con reasonable
computation lead us to the correct
solution and why we would most of the
talk talk about this set up the
phenomena that we will point out
actually happens in a lot of other
related problems that are not of the
form of linear inverse problem for
example denoising problems a variety of
denoising and
regression problems and a bunch of other
problems some of which will show up
later in the talk okay so two key
ingredients are present in solving these
kinds of problems one is the structure
of the signal that we want to try and
recover and here is where the convex
geometry associated to the to the
structure and to computation and the
friendly methods to approach that
structure show up and also second
ingredient is randomness and typically
this is in the measurements or the
observations or the samples and the two
together inter have a nice interplay
there's a big surge of activity in
research areas that revolve around this
problem first one is compressed sensing
from late 90s until now there has been a
lot of research going on in this area it
has impacted image and signal processing
applications especially but also many
other applications we will see some
concrete applications soon also the area
of machine learning or also what's known
as subset of statistics known as high
dimensional statistics which includes
problems like recommender systems or
regular eyes regression and M estimators
or last so if you are familiar with any
of these learning graphical models and
so on and finally another area that has
been this study but I mean let's studied
from this point of view is the area of
dynamical systems the study of dynamical
systems and here for example finding the
order dynamical systems or
identification of systems is relevant to
to this type of problem so what do we
mean by structure we start by the
simplest one talking about vectors in RN
which only have a few nonzero entries so
this is the vector the colored ones are
the nonzero entries everything else is
zero you can imagine this happens in an
appropriate basis could be coordinate
basis or other basis so that's one type
of structure another type of structure
is when we are dealing with data that is
in the form of a matrix let's say n by n
matrix and it has a low rank meaning it
can be factorized into the product of
two matrices of size n times something
much smaller than n that is our that's
the rank of the matrix and our times
n
and this comes up in the recommendation
problem for example on the dynamical
systems problems and there are others as
well
for example group sports vectors where
you have groups of nonzero entries
appearing in a vector and also some of
low rank and sports objects and this
will come up and later in the talk as
well so these are the types of
structures we are interested in and
they're all somewhat capturing being low
dimensional in an appropriate basis one
problem that we will definitely discuss
in the talk is and comes later is when
you have objects that have more than one
such structure at the same time these
are called simultaneous structures so
for example one example is if you have
an object they say a matrix that is both
sparse and low rank at the same time and
this arises in several application
problems we will see soon or you can
have a signal that is both sports and
piecewise constant for example each of
these again are individual structures
that could be studied separately but you
have an object that has both another
application is when you have tensors
that have low torque your rank and
Tucker rank is the rank of all the
unfoldings so when you unfold the tensor
in all different ways and look at the
rank of these unfolded matrices that
also is a can be viewed as several
structures at the same time in one
object alright so applications of this
the biggest application of compressed
sensing so so many of you have seen it
is in magnetic resonance imaging in MRI
and this actually there's a popular
article written in Wired magazine in
2010 about it it's quite interesting to
read so what happens in MRI is that you
have signals that either in the space
domain or in the frequency domain are
very sparse or have a sparse
representation that's an and this is an
angiogram for example where you can see
that it's basically a contrast based
image that already in the space domain
is very sparse but when they also do a
contrast enhancement it becomes even
more sparse and this one corresponds to
a brain image that is in the frequency
domain radio frequency and there are not
too many non-zeroes
along each of these radial direct
so compared to the ambient dimension of
these signals which is pixel by pixel
that large number of pixels the
complexity of them represented by the
the sparsity in a basis is actually
quite small and so the goal is that and
I do the impact of compressed sensing is
that it has given systematic methods to
do faster acquisition and high quality
reconstruction in this MRI setting and
very interesting application area
another example is dealing with low rank
matrix example this is also very very
typical so recommendation system you can
view the database of all the users and
all the movies as a big matrix and the
rankings that users give to movies as
entries of that matrix and typically
some of these entries a few of them are
known most of the others are not known
and you would like to guess and fill in
the unknown ones and this can come up in
any recommender system even in these
other settings recommending objects or
books to users etc so I think many of
you have seen this hopefully this was
very popular because of the Netflix
competition some years ago but the key
is that this is an example of a low rank
matrix and the reason the the overall
ratings matrix is low rank is that you
can factorize it as a something that is
movie features and users features so
because only a few factors really affect
each user stays and in practice also you
can see that it is low rank some
practical evidence for it as well
the third example is in the one in
control theory or system identification
so here you have a black box dynamical
system let's say D in your dynamical
system you pick a signal input signal to
apply to your system and observe the
outputs and these are time series now so
this is a time series that's a time
series and suppose you observe some kind
of a noisy output for example you obtain
upper and lower bounds on the output or
you obtain the output plus some Wiggly
noise and you would like to reconstruct
the dynamics the unknown dynamics here
and the order of the system which
captures the complexity of a linear
dynamical system is actually the rank of
an Associated Hanko matrix and so it
actually is a rank minimization
problem as well or a low-rank
reconstruction problem and the the
randomness and noise could be in your
inputs or also noise and the outputs
usually you try to pick or randomize
your input a little bit to twist the
system in different directions so to
speak
and finally the other another example is
first we is talking about a problem
called phase retrieval which is a
problem in optics where you are
measuring so you have actually some
x-ray source and a sample or an object
that the x-ray is hitting going through
some mask and then hitting this image
plane and a diffraction pattern is
formed and what happens in phase
retrieval is that from this diffraction
pattern you can only measure intensities
but not phase this is called phase this
measurement we will see the details
later and in this set of what happens is
you can view your measurements as linear
in terms of a matrix that is a Rank 1
outer product of the true signal you are
trying to reconstruct and so that's
called the phase retrieval problem and
it was studied for example in this paper
you can see more about it there and as
well as others it has been very popular
problem recently but I would like to
also point out the sparse phase
retrieval problem which is the studied
which is you want to do the face
retrieval but you also know that each of
these vectors you are trying to
reconstruct is also sports so you have
two structures both Rank 1 and sparse
and this fact this issue of being sports
and orange for example also arises in
sports principal component analysis in
cluster detection and several other
problems we'll see some of them later
ok so the talk is organized around
basically these examples will first talk
about force vectors that's our example
one that the MRI example and then the
example 2 & 3 the system ID problem and
the recombination problem deal with low
ranked matrices the third one is
actually a simultaneous structure
problem we'll talk about what's known
about it and there are very interesting
open questions by the time we get to
simultaneous structures that we'll
discuss
so first sparse signal recovery ok this
is definitely the part that will bore
many of you but let's do it very quickly
so this is one view of it but it's
particularly simple view that one can do
very quickly all right so this is my
sparse vector that I'm making measure
and self this is my measurement matrix
I'm multiplying the matrix with the with
the vector and I'm getting this vector Y
and in general if this matrix as we is a
big fat matrix is not full rank it's
losing information so one can't recover
X given Y but keep in mind you're only
interested in sparse vectors what does
that mean well X only had a few nonzero
so it means it's only selecting a few
columns out of the big matrix so we're
not interested in recovering any vector
but only its first vector so what if so
this problem is not that bad now because
this matrix is not full rank full column
rank and so what if the fine matrix was
such that all in my case of matrices
will full rank then it sounds like we
should be in an easier situation and
that intuition is actually true and
here's how to formalize it this is a
property it's actually historically the
first property that or one of the first
properties studied for this problem but
there are many other properties as well
that capture essentially the same idea
this one is called restricted isometry
property and it appeared in canvas
Romberg towel paper in 2004 so it says
this is one way to express it it says
that the if the map Foy my remeasurement
map is such that when it's I think on
two different distinct key sparse
vectors its distance is the ratio of the
output distance over the input distance
is close to one then we are in good
shape why because if I take two
different case force vectors this is
these are each K dimensional sub spaces
x1 is 1 case force signal and this is
another one if I take two different ones
and it goes through this map the output
or is far apart so it can be told apart
so we are not losing information in that
sense now we can also see why we have so
this is close to 1 this gain the ratio
of the output of them up to the input is
close to 1 within some factor Delta 2k
and this is Delta through K because we
are looking at each vector X's case
worse than x1 minus x2 is 2k sports
anyways so what didn't what does it mean
it also means that the singular values
of 2 white 2 K columns sub matrices that
have two K columns of matrix 4 I have to
be close to 1 so it's a property of the
singular values if that's the case then
recovery will be okay and intuitively it
agrees with our intuition that er we are
in a good situation
and so intuition is that the map
preserves the geometry of sparse vectors
or sparse signals and more generally
there's a much better or more general
property that captured the same idea
restricted strong convexity or
restricted eigen value property and
there are other conditions but the
intuition is similar and this one is
easier to draw at a very very basic
level now the question is okay how do I
pick a matrix Phi that has this nice
property that satisfies this property
well if you give me a matrix to check it
I have to enumerate all possible sub
matrices so that's hard it's exponential
in the number of columns however there
is some interesting deep insight from
70s and Gaussian and the caution that a
random matrix does have this property
with high probability in the following
sense if I take your matrix whose
entries are iid Gaussian or they're iid
plus minus 1 burn only and there's a
whole host of other distributions I can
pick from by the way is related to
Johnson in this Ross lemma so any
Johnson insurance matrix and they'd also
don't need to be our idea cetera from
these families if I sample a Phi then it
satisfies the property that I desired
with a probability that goes to 1
exponentially as M which is the number
of rows of the matrix grows and the C is
a constant that depends on that Delta
constant in the previous slide and if
this happens with high probability in M
if M is on the order of basically K
times log of n and over K but the
dominance is K log N and this
interesting thing is this number is much
much less than in it's basically
proportional to K and log of n so it's
much smaller than n so we can basically
do reconstruction with minimal number of
measurements and
this is information theoretically tight
now so how do we do reconstruction this
tells you that it's possible to
reconstruct whether it with the right
way let's try to guess what the right
way would be well first we constructing
a signal given linear measurement means
I have this subspace where my X can live
in right and I want to pick one vector
now they want it to be sparse so maybe
the first thing that comes to mind is
let's take the minimum energy vector in
that subspace that is the minimum l2
norm
closest to the origin but then even from
this very simple picture you see that's
not going to be sparse this is the
sports solution but this one is not and
this is very typical l 2-norm solution
is almost never sparse and well known
however as you all well know the thing
that works or the norm that does the
right thing is a one norm the unit norm
a unit norm ball of l1 norm is cross
volatile that it looks like this it has
sharp corners and in this figure and
actually with high probability most of
the time it actually hits the right
sparse signal at one of its corners so
minimizing the l1 norm which means you
blow up this ball from origin until it
hits this hyper plane and you get that
point that actually gives you this force
signal and so here is the result here's
the formal result for this scenario that
it says that l1 minimization for random
for example Gaussian and there were
versions for the other distributions
that I mentioned as long as basically
you have the appropriate concentration
of singular values the reconstruction
with a 1 norm succeeds with high
probability if M is on the order of K
log N and there are there are many other
related results around the same time as
well ok now why oh why does l1 norm work
and why do we use our 1 or essentially
what we are interested in where sparse
vectors so it could be this vector for
example it has one entry nonzero or this
one this one and this is a discrete set
and we all know that this is a hard set
to search over it's intractable
however searching over is convex Hall
which is the one
unis ball is much better and in fact the
insight about a won reconstruction
already existed from long time ago in
fact people were using it in the 60s and
70s especially in geophysics and then
later in statistics but the rigorous
results go back to very late 90s and
2000's one way to see what why what
cases work and what cases don't work in
the reconstruction is to look at the
this is the o1 normal and this red
region is the sub space that is the
where my measurements can live and what
happens is the question is whether the
sub space crosses into the ball or not
because if it does not cross into the
ball the minimizer of l1 norm subject to
being on the sub space is this point
which is the right signal but if the
signal was here and the sub space
actually crossed into the ball the
minimizing l1 norm will give you this
point which is not the correct solution
so this is the case in which you cannot
recover your signal and this is a good
case so the result essentially means
with high probability the good case
happens and it means that most in random
subspaces don't cross into the one ball
with high probability and and this
result can be extended to having noisy
measurements which basically means you
put a tube around this hyperplane and
your X lives there and you get a robust
result which basically says you're not
too far from the true signal within this
much error so you can actually give
robust versions of the recovery as well
all right so hopefully that was a that
was a quick review of recovering sparse
signals but keep the keep in mind the
main idea was a one Norman its main and
role and this geometry now for
long-range matrices what's the low rank
matrix what's the meaning of rank
there are many meanings one is that the
rank of a matrix is dimension of the
span of the rows it's also the dimension
of the span of the columns it's the
smallest number or such as I can factor
the matrix into a product of two
matrices where the middle size is R and
it's also the number of nonzero singular
values they're all definitions
equivalent interventions of rank
linear inverse problem
for recovering and reconstructing a low
rank matrix is find the matrix that has
rank or that satisfies some linear
equations we can represent it by a fine
map on the matrix so a is a linear map
from an SI n by n matrices to RM and we
can also stack it into a big matrix and
stack all the entries of the matrix into
a big vector so we can just write it as
a vector matrix product as well all
right what is the geometry of this
object the set of low rank matrices we
saw the set of sparse vectors were on
the coordinate axis for set of lower
rank matrices as much harder to
visualize but if you have a two-by-two
matrix is not that hard so here we take
your 2x2 matrix and we draw in 3d so the
variables are X Y Z is a symmetric
matrix 3 3 variables and we can draw the
set of matrices that get make this rank
instead of to be 1 and you get the set
of red points here and the red points
here so every point here corresponds to
an XYZ that gives you a rank one matrix
for example this one corresponds to this
matrix that's trying one this one
corresponds to this one that is also
rank one okay and well so this would go
to infinity because we can always scale
the matrix these are normalized so
they're Farabee Gnaeus norm where L 2
norm is set to 1 ok good so now if I
have linear equations on the object and
I wanted to hit at the right point a
point that is lower rank it means that I
have a hyperplane that I would like it
to hit at the boundary of this set can I
do that by minimizing the convex hull of
this set and the answer is actually yes
so early on actually in work with
Stephen Boyd we looked at the nuclear
norm of a matrix and its relation to
rank and we looked we here sickly
propose that as a way to minimize rank
or get a lower rank matrix what is the
nuclear norm is the sum of the singular
values of the matrix and so Sigma I is
the I singular value and it's
essentially playing a very similar role
to l1 norm for the for the vector like
sum of absolute values of entries and
minimizing this this can be written as a
semi-definite program so therefore
they're efficient algorithms to solve it
efficient in the sense of going on your
time but practical methods we'll discuss
a little bit later well so if you let X
be a diagonal matrix you get back your
l1 so this is Gerren dicing do one
situation and you can view the nuclear
norm as a one norm of the vector of
singular values and note that actually
when we take look at this convex and
it's the convex hull of the rank one the
unit normal is the convex sort of the
rank one matrices that we drew before
and when we minimize the norm subject to
being in this subspace we hit at one of
the corner points of the ball which is a
rank one matrix so in that sense it has
a sharp corner
note that the shortness includes
curvature and that's fine it's still
sharp for our purposes and go make that
more precise later about algorithm so
this is just an aside because in this
talk we won't discuss algorithms of how
do you actually solve this no clear nor
minimization problem to recover a matrix
we just said it's an SDP it's a semi
definite program so many algorithm can
be used to solve that as CP and there
are some specific ones of course we can
use interior point methods and
specialize it to the structure of your
problem proximal gradient methods a
whole host of first-order methods with
different acronyms and block coordinate
descent etc so there are many choices
but there's also a recent interest in
trying to parameterize the low rank
matrix as a product of two matrices with
the appropriate size that upper bounds
the rank and then use non convex
optimization on that parameterize form
and this idea goes back to where n want
a row but it has gained a lot of recent
interest you can do either gradient
descent on that factorized form
non convex problem or alternating
minimization so it's not complex so you
have to work very hard to show anything
works but it does actually work in some
settings so for example for recovering
your rank matrices in specific problems
like matrix completion or several other
interesting problems
another interesting new direction is
that one reason people actually use this
fine
an approach is that the size of this
matrix is which is a variable in the
optimization problem is n by n is very
large whereas each of these guys are n
by r where r is usually very small so
it's the memory issue you want your
algorithm to save memory and another
alternative way to do that instead of
writing in an factorize way and in some
some problems is to use a sketched
convex formulation or an algorithm that
is based on conditional ingredients
descent on the dual problem together
with a keeping and a sketch of the
matrix so that we can reconstruct the
solution from the solution of the dual
the primal from network so this is
another approach that is really convex
optimization but it has a memory
footprint on the order of the non convex
factorization so these are two
interesting algorithmic directions for
how to save computation and memory along
these lines but I want this custom any
further in this time so why does the
clear norm work and what what's the
what's and sample context it was the
number of measurements you need so going
back to the original setup we had where
measurement is a random let's say random
Gaussian measurement in our work with
with Ben and cogno be sure that you only
need the order of n times R times log n
where this log and was just an artifact
and it can actually be dropped so the
order of measurements think it is n
times R so size of the matrix times the
rank which and interestingly is actually
the degrees of freedom of a rank R
matrix so it's pretty good information
theoretically as well so even to just
write down such a matrix you need on the
order of n times or entries because the
number of numbers here is 2 n 2 and R
and if you do the counting is on that
order so that is good no clear norm does
work then one of our motivating
applications was this problem of filling
in the movie ratings and recommendation
problem and there's no Gaussian
measurement here but well the proofs are
much more complicated still if you can
if you make some assumptions on the
matrix on some assumptions on the
randomness of the observed entries
things still work so for a large class
of X thoughts it
they do work and this led to the results
of Canada's unwritten day and a lot of
variations on it and simplifications of
it that came later essentially says that
no clear nor minimisation recovers in
coherent matrices that have rank or from
order of n times R times poly log in n
which is really nice that's again the
degrees of freedom of the matrix and
incoherence means basically that you're
just avoiding matrices that cannot be
reconstructed by looking at their
entries things where entries are all in
certain parts of the matrix and they're
not spread out but if the entries are
spread out in an appropriate sense then
things are okay so the geometric picture
is a bit similar to what we had before
in all of these problems we have nice
sharp corners at the object of interest
the unit norm ball that of the norm that
you're minimizing has a nice sharp
corner at the point of interest one more
problem that is very interesting and
again has similar flavor even though the
setup is different is matrix
decomposition or D mixing here you are
given a matrix C and you are told it's a
summation of a low rank of a sparse
matrix and a low rank matrix what both
are unknown and you want to actually
recover forgiven see the sparse part and
the lower end part there could also be a
compressed measurement version of this
in which you are given compressed
measurements of the C and you still want
to reconstruct the C so for this problem
initially this was studied by
Chandrasekaran at all and the result is
that yeah you can actually separate when
and the question is when can we do this
solve this the mixing problem so you can
do it under some noise condition and go
condition between certain subspaces that
basically ensures that a and B are
separable there's no confusion between
them and the condition essentially means
that the low rank part is not too sparse
and the sparse part is not too low right
once that is satisfied then it's
possible to do the separation and this
is
interesting problem it has many
applications so for example one can be
that the low ranked part is capturing
some lower low order relation between
some variables and the sparse part are
some anomaly so anomaly detection or
graphical models with latent variables
for example where the latent variable
part is captured by this low rank part
and many other applications and there's
a whole host of other papers as well and
for example this paper by by trop
actually gives a a view that is similar
to the cone analysis that you will see
later for this problem
so this problem it looks different but
again similar ideas and and techniques
apply under the right assumption one can
solve it and do the D mixing you can
also have noisy version of it you can
have noise added etc and again there are
robust versions as well so what's the
most general among all of these things
that we have seen and this is paper
again by Venkata Chandrasekaran and ben
pablo and an induce key and I like it a
lot because it clarifies the picture of
what what you should do once you have
certain structures so they actually give
you a recipe you start by atoms so you
want to your object of interest is a
linear combination of only a few atoms
and you start from the atoms normalize
them take their convex hull and you get
a normal with some technical assumption
get a gauge function what can't
correspond to a norm and then suppose
this blue set is the norm ball and then
the signal that you're trying to
reconstruct let's say it's this X and
the soft space it lives in that soft
space that is consistent with your
measurements is the green one and so X
is the unique minimizer if the
intersection of the cone of all the
directions that point inward to the ball
with the subspace is only going to be at
the origin or with the null space of
your measurement map is that one yet
origin so if this holds then you can
reconstruct X by minimizing the norm
induced by this set
and this is very interesting in general
result its crucially relies on a lemma
by Gordon in also known as the escape
from the mesh lemma that for inverse
problems as a result of this the number
of measurements linear measurements one
needs to reconstruct an object that has
that is a combination of only a few of
the vertices of this ball is on the
order of it has the the number of
measurements has to be related to the
quantity called the Gaussian width of
this cone of this descent cone so what
is Gaussian width is for every cone is
defined like that so it's expected value
of the largest inner product of
everything in this set with a random
Gaussian vector and in some in some ways
it's measuring how wide your cone is at
this point and this generalizes this
intuitive notion of shortness we saw for
the l1 ball and for the nuclear normal
so it's very nice there there's this
nice geometric picture for everything
that works now I want to talk about a
set of problems so so far it seems like
in this area everything's solved right
everything works great perfect
there are hard problems left and I want
to actually talk about even something
that initially might seem very simple
ends up not being simple and this is the
case where you have one object that you
would like to reconstruct but you know
this object has several structures at
the same time called simultaneous
structures so we just mentioned one of
the examples would be sparse phase
retrieval here is the phase retrieval
problem in a little bit more detail so I
would like to recover a signal X naught
from linear measurements that are called
faceless measurements because they have
an absolute value so a linear
measurement meaning there is a
measurement vector AI transpose you take
the inner product with your signal X
naught that's an inner measurement but
then there's an absolute value you're
given only the sine order or the
magnitude of a complex number if it's in
the complex domain and that's your
measurement and the question is how many
of these measurements how big should M
be for us to be able to find a way to
reconstruct the X naught from these
measurement
so so far this is the face retrieval
problem and you can be formulated by a
trick that you guys are many of you are
very familiar with which is lifting you
define a new matrix that is the outer
product of your single with itself call
it X and now my measurements these
things if I square both sides and this
is the same as the inner product of a I
AI transpose with X naught X naught
transpose so I can write it like that so
now I have measurements that are linear
in my variable X right they're linear in
X however X has to be constrained to be
Rank 1 so it's an orange reconstruction
problem so far I'm looking for a matrix
that's positive 7 event rank 1 and
agrees with some linear measurements so
falls under what we discussed about
nuclear norm but we are interested in
the case where the signal is also sports
or has a sports representation in some
basis in that case there's two things
going on not only this matrix is ranked
1 but it's factors or sports so it's
outer product of that say case force
factors its Rank 1 and sport and for
example blocks force ok so that's the
type of problem you're interested in two
structures at the same time so let's
look at that a little bit more for money
so object X naught has several
structures at the same time and these
are let's say familiar structures for
each individual one we already know a
norm that works so sparsity well I know
I do l1 minimization for that no
rankness well I know I'll do I'll do
nucleon or minimization so individually
when understood structures each of these
structures come with a structure
promoting norm and now we have more than
one structure so it should help us we
should be reducing the degrees of
freedom of the object we want to
reconstruct and a typical approach
that's used in practice in fact I have
seen this quite often is if you want to
induce several structures in your model
why not minimize an objective function
that combines those individual norms
subject to your measurements so the
question is with this work now this is
written very generally for example this
is a composition of a function H with
these individual norms where H is any
function from R plus R cross that is
convex and it's non decreasing in each
argument this assumption is
so that the composition remains convex
in hex you want to get a convex
optimization problem and under the
composition rule this will still give me
something convex what are a specific
examples what are a specific ways to
combine these norms well you can take a
linear combination with some
coefficients land or some tuning
parameters and Oi
you can take the point wise maximum with
some tuning parameters both of these
result in a specific age and these are
these are a tuning parameters alpha I or
land oi okay all right so we want to
understand whether the solution of this
optimization problem or when for how
many measurements would the solution of
this optimization problem be X naught
because X naught is the structured
object that I took the linear
measurements from okay okay if there are
any questions by the way stop me
especially in this part okay so what
time what am I doing here and actually
solving a multi objective optimization
from there are several objectives here
right that are combined together with
this function H so it makes sense to
look at the Perito optimal front so I
have norm number one corresponding to
structure number one or number two
across my into structure - and I will
plot so I will pick an M number M as
number of measurements and then I carry
out these measurements on my signal X
naught and then we look at the set of
all achievable XS and take their norms
l1 and l2 norms and basically shade the
region of space that is above the curve
that satisfies these constraints so that
gives you the Pareto optimal set and the
boundary of that set is the Pareto
optimal curve that shows when you are
moving if you fix em as you move along
these this curve you are trading off
these two norms with each other
now I've put X naught here X naught does
not live in this plane but I what I
meant is that this particular point
corresponds to the correct X naught the
signal that I want to reconstruct now we
can see that this is just a cartoon but
the idea is if the number of
measurements is too low for example I
have m1 measurements then that pays off
too
while yet is this one which has really
nothing to do with the signal I'm trying
to find so as I go along this curve
there is no hope of finding X naught but
when the number of measurements M
increases I'll eventually get curves
that actually do have X naught
corresponding to a point on their
boundary so the point is when things are
failing it's not really what combination
of nor should I take any combination is
going to fail so it's not the tuning
parameter language that's causing the
problem
neither is what kind of H function I
feel so in the case where things do work
I have enough measurements and it's not
the true signal corresponds to a point
on the Perito curve then I can recover
it by picking the lando appropriately so
then I'll endure is the slope of this
line or I can even do it by picking the
point wise maximum which is corresponds
to its level set corresponds to this
square thing which hits at the right
point so once things are recovered what
I can do it in multiple ways but the
problem is not being recoverable
recovery failure so when does recovery
fail well that's actually not hard to
write down for this optimization problem
so now it's a convex problem we can
write down the optimality conditions for
it and one particular arrangement of the
optimality condition gives us this
inequality that if some this side of
inequality is bigger than this side then
X naught is not the minimizer of the
optimization problem and recovery fails
so this is basically writing the
optimality conditions and flipping it to
get something that does not hold and the
reason you're doing this is that to
obtain a condition that says you need at
least a certain number of measurements
for the problem to work now what does
the theorem say what does this site say
well so this side the left hand side is
the minimum over all vectors in the sub
differential of F at X naught the
minimum of the inner product of the
normalized vectors in the sub
differential and the normalized true
signal so these bars just mean
normalization with l2 norm so this is
looking at the angles between my signal
and the sub differential of the function
that I am minimizing
this side is actually only depends on my
measurement matrix a and on the signal X
naught so this side depends on the
function I'm minimizing F and this side
depends on a the measurement so this
notation by the way is the set of sub
gradients of the function f ethics not
one property that we crucially will use
is that when you have a composition of a
scale of H with these norms B sub
differential of this function every
element of the sub differential can be
written as a linear combination of
individual sub gradients so you have a
summation of some weights WI times G I
where G is a sub gradient of each other
and in fact that's where the bottleneck
comes from let's look at this a little
bit more so the left hand side of the
inequality depends only on the function
that we are minimizing the cost of the
panel is a ssin and the signal and this
thing cannot be made very small because
sub gradients are actually aligned with
the signal so it's a set of sub
differential has some alignment with the
true signal so this inner product cannot
be made very small and just intuitively
and the right-hand side depends only on
the measurements matrix a and the true
signal and if I look at this side and I
try to upper bound it all I need to do
is to basically four random matrices
just use a lot of results from random
matrix theory that says l2 norm of a
random matrix times a vector or the
Sigma min of that vector of that random
matrix are bounded or how they
concentrate and so on and for many
random ensembles including Gaussian but
also many more this side actually scales
as square root of M over N where m is
the number of measurements so mm-my n is
the size of this matrix a and M is the
number of measurements and n is the
ambient dimension of X so I'm
eliminating the proofs but if you have
any questions I can show you later
essentially the idea is what we
that we lower bound very crudely this
side by using geometry of the sub
differential and we upper bound this
side also crudely using concentration
putting these two together so we
basically say this won't hold if if this
holds so as long as M is less than some
constant times n times this quantity
then the recovery program does not work
so this is a condition for the previous
condition to hold so recovery will not
work X dot is not the minimizer as long
as the M is too small so M has to be at
least this quantity okay what is this
quantity so the key thing is that this
is actually this Kappa mean is the
minimum of the Kappa I Kappa I is a
geometric quantity associated to each of
the individual norms and what it is is
that it's the ice norm of the signal we
are trying to reconstruct divided by the
Lipschitz constant of that norm and what
is doing is that this quantity is
measuring the ratio of the ice norm 12
to norm or in in the proper signal that
we are trying to reconstruct and the
ellipsis constant is the ratio of the
change of the norm over l 2-norm
everywhere and so this is basically how
sharp your norm in some some measure of
that but the key thing is among all of
the individual norms the minimum of them
appears here so you don't really get
interactions between the norms one of
them dominates your bound and to make it
more concrete let's look at some
examples so if I for example wanted to
minimize l1 norm so these are the
familiar ones we showed before if I
minimize a1 norm to recover a case force
vector my niblets constant is gonna be
square root n and the norm of the true
signal case for signal is l2 norm of it
is square root K so when I put them
together here M should be at least n
times square of this thing divided by
this thing so you get actually K so good
for to recover a case force vector you
need m to be at this K and we know the
true number is K log n this is also true
about column sparse matrices or
or group sports where you will be
minimizing your one two norm and here
are the numbers and the number of
measurements you need is K times D so in
this case my matrix is of size D by D
and K columns were nonzero and now I
have a rank R matrix that is D by D the
number of measurements with no clear
norm is going to be R times D which is
again the right number that we have seen
before so basically we reproduce
everything we knew so far with it
whenever we have a single structure but
let's look at the first example where we
put together two structures here we have
the nuclear norm and the one norm
combine them any way you want
the measurements needs to be at this
minimum of K Square and R times D but
the true degrees of freedom of this
object should be K times R so this is
the wrong scaling in the K so this this
is where you see a gap and actually you
can also show a gap in a little bit more
detailed way for a problem that combines
the nuclear norm and l1 to norm for
groups bars but I will I will skip this
because I want to point out one more
thing there is another problem that
seems a little bit different but runs
into the exact same bottleneck so the
problem we talked about so far was a
linear inverse problem you were
reconstructing an object given
measurements right and you are asking
for the minimum number of measurements
for the reconstruction to work and now
this problem is different problems the
physicians are often interested in it's
called the noising problem so the
noising means that there is a structured
signal X naught again in our end
I have noisy observations of it so I
have X naught plus some noise where
noise is let's say Gaussian 0 mean unit
variance so I had noise to it and then I
asked the question how much noise can
you tolerate and yet to be able to
exactly recover X naught or not exactly
recover X not in the way that scales the
right way with the noise but the
variance of the noise so one way to do
it is this regularize these squares
denoiser it's a very common approach so
you build an estimator for the x given
the measurements Y that minimizes that
this
between why and examine also penalizes
or regularizes using an appropriate norm
that took the structure of the unknown
object into account so for example if
it's a sports vector you want to
reconstruct you will plug in a 1 on here
or no clear not and so by the way this
is a minimizer of this simple problem is
nothing but proximal operator also known
as the procs operator of the norm of
lambda times the norm at Y so this
proximal denoiser is very common and
nice things have been understood about
it for single structure case now in in
statistics and at least a subset of
literature's that deal with this problem
then the error of an estimator is
measured as this mean square error risk
which is defined as follows it's the
worst case error that you can have in
your reconstruction so this is the
reconstructed signal as a function of
the noisy measurements minus the true
signal this is the largest possible
error over there signal-to-noise ratios
gamma is the SNR signal to noise ratio
so a model of signal-to-noise ratios
take the worst case and that is the
error so that's the worst case error and
you want to then you call that as your
MSE as a function of lambda lambda is a
parameter in the problem now you can
optimize over your parameter as well so
minimize over all Lando's this error so
that's in some sense a minimax mean
square error risk so over all tunings
under this is the best one ok so what
happens if you plug in the simple known
structures so for an X in RN that's the
case for specter denoising with l1 norm
gives you and MSE error that scales on
the order of K log n which is good again
the degrees of freedom of T of the X
naught object case force vector and if
it's a rank or matrix again this error
annoying with nuclear norm gives you MSE
that scales with n times R again the
right information theoretic one and
these are results from various papers
Donoho and
canary and others but what happens if
you have multiple structures if you have
a lower bound we can give a lower bound
on the MSE risk for the case of multiple
structures and I won't give any of the
proof but actually one simple geometric
thing is that what you can do is that
the error is never better than the
quantity that is determined by the
largest angle between any of the
individuals of differentials and your
signal so among all the sub
differentials this is for norm one this
is for norm to pick the vector that has
a largest angle with the true signal you
are trying to reconstruct and that
dominates your mean square error so that
means again the structures are not
helping reduce the total error it's
dominated by only the one of these
individual structures so the one with
largest set of dominates and this is a
simple way to see that again you have
the same bottleneck as before that
combining the structures so this is by
the way I took the linear combination of
the structures like that but it's also
true if you take again composed with a
function H that is convex and monotonic
and it's variables and also the same
result extends to the case where you
don't don't just do denoising what
you're doing a regression so you have
the measurement map in here and you have
noise and you're using the regularizer
to reconstruct so this is a typical
estimation problem in statistics again
with multiple structures combining
regular Reiser's hits the same issue ok
so this brings us to I think what's the
most interesting part in the talk which
is this problem is still open what does
one do when you have multiple structures
in one object so we showed a very
general negative result a whole bunch of
things don't work right but what can
work so likely there it would be a
case-by-case solution for each type of
structure but one of the the most
popular combination of structures is low
rank and sparse so matrix that is
jointly low rank and sparse and by the
way I want to point out that this
relaxing
the Lawrences and sparseness
individually using your 1-norm and
nuclear Nord also appears in many
typical SCP relaxations where implicitly
being lower rank is relaxed to being in
the PSD cone as a constraint and then
there is some like trace that is being
minimized that's basically equivalent to
no clear norm for symmetric and PSD
matrices so whenever you have x+ 7f and
under trace in the objective and at the
same time you want some kind of an entry
way structure and you use our one norm
or summation or equality constraints on
the entries usually this means you are
handling your entry wise part of this
structure and the spectral part of the
structure separately and perhaps this is
why a lot of these STP relaxations have
limitations so very very very but so
what can one do in each case one can
first try to find a better penalty maybe
the combination of the individual norms
isn't the best thing so one thing is
going back to that atomic norm framework
and see if one can identify the right
atoms sector convex hull and see if one
can get anything that's definitely
possible if it can be done however for
example for sports on dornan case it's
actually interactable to do then people
have proposed different sort of
heuristic we build approximations to try
to improve and then there have been some
improvements but not otherwise you still
stuck in the same order what constants
have been improved for specific problems
of combining law Rankin spars and then
this one was for unfolding of tensors
the low to high rank tensor and also
another line of work has looked at their
measurements if you if you have the
ability or freedom to construct the
measurement map in a very specific way
you can get around this problem but
usually that's not available so for
example if you can do nested
measurements you first make measurements
that respect the sparsity and then on
top of that make measurements that
respect the low rank and so on so that's
possible but only very restricted
applications would allow such a thing
now one interesting thing is that that I
have been thinking about since the
recent workshop in the in this program
about as well as hierarchies and they're
very recent paper that actually
a lot of people here have worked on yes
Hopkins store so either and others
actually shows on the problem of sparse
PCA which is an example of a problem
that has low ranked transport structures
together that there are exponential
lower bounds on SOS algorithms and so it
kind of hints this is a very hard
problem what would be interesting to see
if this machinery can be also used for
other combinations of structures either
give positive or negative results
whether gaps can be bridged or they
cannot be with point normal time
algorithms so I think that's very
interesting
open question and with that I would like
to just thank everyone first the
collaborators and also Simon's Institute
for this amazing program and thank you
all for listening
[Applause]